[Musique]
voir les enfants
comment
[Musique]
que se passe-t-il patron mon petit doigt
me dit qu'il y a des enfants qui ne
veulent pas aller au lit le soir
lorsqu'il est l'heure de dormir mais ce
très grand sens où jovem frh nom ne te
fâche pas nounours
ce soir ils veulent te faire une
surprise oui et ils vont se coucher très
gentiment alors ils sont mes amis mon
échelle je descends voir ce qui se passe
en bas hier peu pompeux pom pom boy
il était là me tartine et en importe pas
là de porc frais la muraille était de
pralines élèves parquet était à croquer
la chambre à coucher et crème de lait
l'élu de biscuits les rideaux dany
elle épousa monsieur gillett et coiffé
d'un fromage blanc son chapeau n 2 de
galettes de son avis et des vingt neuf
ans qu'il a tenu qu'à un fil et chocolat
pas de caramel et souliers demierre
leur fille ella fait charlotte après
année de master de très belles dents de
compote des oreilles de craquelins je la
vois garnir sa robe de plaisir avec un
rouleau le pack abricots
le gel et prince limonade bien frisé à
terre sa courte us et blue cheveux de
marmelade orné de pommes cuites au four
sont royalement dont deux petits gâteaux
et de raisin ses forces et au respect
voici qu'elle a fait car au poste
jalouse est de mauvaise humeur
transversale d'un coup de sa poche le
palais sucré du bonheur pour leur bâti
nous donner à loisir tenez bon parent et
suppose enfants
merci les enfants j'aime beaucoup cette
chanson je me suis régalé il ne me
manque plus qu'un test
tout arrive à point à qui sait attendre
[Musique]
comme tu tombe bien baby tard merci ma
petite pépite à mes n'ai pas peur aux
messages à la bourse on est joué tout
l'après midi à kashgar huit ans elle en
connaît les cachettes des pétards vient
pipita vient me faire un col mais ne te
sors pas pépites à
penser en ours vous avait effrayé cet
enfant je ne voulais pas la manger je
voulais lui faire un petit col
hottinguer de panne ou qu ils
s'habitueront on s'habitue à tout et là
nous rappeler tétouan
bonne nuit les petits
bon appétit cher mourepiane
bonis ou net
[Musique]
ah voilà nounours bon appétit vous
voulez goûter non merci nounours tu as
été gâté pepita nous apporter un plein
panier de belles pommes
ce que lin sauvage il faut être plus
doux avec elle mais je suis tout pas
trop je suis do we nounours bonne nuit
des enfants allez vite vous coucher est
fait pour
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]